[Musique]
pour moi l'europe c'est avant tout une
histoire commune une histoire entre des
peuples c'est avant tout des nations
c'est une civilisation qui se
rassemblent sur des racines
judéo-chrétiennes
nous partageons une histoire commune
nous partageons une culture commune
l'europe avant tout ça me suggère
évidemment une zone de paix une zone où
les dirigeants sont élus
démocratiquement
une zone qui fait une grande part à la
liberté d'expression la liberté des
journalistes
mais il ya aussi l'égalité finalement
c'est la devise française l'europe
liberté égalité l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes et l'égalité entre
les hommes en général j'ai des enfants
des petits-enfants et alors on pense
vraiment à la peine à une terre
d'opportunités c'est la possibilité
quand on est jeunes de voyager de
rencontrer du monde de parler de
nouvelles langues de faire valoir ses
compétences c'est le projet erasmus qui
permet à des étudiants le tour de
l'europe de partir en échange de passer
un an l'étranger en europe
j'adore je suis européenne je suis
française par mariage
roland des spas renaissance donc le rock
plon moi c'est tous les jours c'est
d'abord l'euro c'est une monnaie commune
c'est ce qui nous a permis d'avoir une
vraie force économique de créer des
réelles géant européen du secteur comme
mariano airbus ça paraît des banalités
aujourd'hui et surtout aux jeunes qui
n'ont rien connu d'autre mais je pense
qu'il faut être très vigilant pour
conserver toutes ses qualités de
l'europe l'europe est une priorité et
surtout un très beau projet d'avenir
[Musique]
à